Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
And, inthis video, I'm going to show you our biggest problems.
Or, challenges...
And, we're going to doa Q&A.
So, we're going to answer some questions
from you guys, at the end of this video.
And every eighth video, and I actually do this wrong all the time...
It's not every eighth video,
but every tenth video, but then the eighth of it...
So, number 8, 18, 28, 38, and now we're in number 48.
This is number 58...
Number 68...
So, here we are: update number 78!
The first eighth-problem-video,
of Project Kamp season 3!
So, Season 3 already started
and we have afew challenges popping up...
But, before we go into the new ones,
let me put a bit of context with theold ones.
And, how they relate to each other...
In Season 1, we had a lot of practical challenges,
and somewere pretty easy to solve.
Cleaning the road, an address...
We don't really have a place to sit...
Some werea bit more complex...
So, we need to get water to hook up these containers...
"Do you have electricity?", andthey said: "Yeah, it's easy!"
So, I would say the video making is kind of a challenge actually...
And, some, we still don't really have a solution for...
Quite a thing having all these flies...
Highway sounds.
And, inSeason 2, we had people come in.
Which, also, brought some new practical challenges.
Somewhat easyto fix.
Doing a lot of paperwork...
This beautiful purple Caddy.
Our chairs keep breaking...
But, we alsogot a few bigger challenges coming up, like fire risk.
Which is now part of our long-term planning.
And now, Season 3: more people coming...
So, the challenges are more about scaling up.
So, on the onehand, we have all the practical challenges.
Which, by now, we're not too scared of those anymore.
But, wealso have some more human challenges popping up...
And, let's start off with practical ones!
So, thisyear we are scaling up.
At our peak moment, we will be with 25 people,
which means that it's 10 morepeople, than last year...
More people, more food, more projects, more tools...
That means: also more needfor storage...
We have this container here, that we built for storage.
Which, at the moment, it's just adump place...
We still need to think of a very smart way,
of dividing the container in three places.
How to store materials, how to store tools,
and how to store food.
And, we don't know how to dothat for now...
This brings us to our next challenge,
which is our old storage place: this white tent.
Asyou can see, this is kind of a mess...
We have boxes of veggies, that we get weekly.
A funky trashsystem...
Oranges...
We have all of these windows!
Concrete!
We don't really know how to continuewith this...
We already repaired the windows.
The frame is kind of okay...
Not super stable.
But,we are questioning if we keep the frame,
and put another fabric on top.
Do we use thisfor storage?
Do we use this for shade for the people?
Do we not use this at all?
We don't know,and it's an ongoing challenge,
that we need to figure out...
One of the places, that we are still
within the black hole, is in the waste system...
We have so many cultures,
and in each country werecycle differently.
So, for example, for many people: this is not recyclable.
In some places inPortugal, this is recyclable,
and in some others it's not.
For some people, like, this is clearly plastic, but it's dirty...
So, where do you put it?
So, we are trying to figure out like a simple system,
that people can easily follow.
And, that we can have a clear,
and clean system for the waste.
We are with more people, and we create more waste!
One of the challenges, of 20 people living off-grid,
in this setting, is the electricity.
Because, our electricity consumption scales up,
with theamount of people we are here.
If we don't have sun, for more than three or four days,
our electricitystarts to be tight...
We could scale up our solar energy,
but this comes with some challenges...
Aslike, balancing out our capacity for storage,
and our capacity of production...
So, depending on thetime of the year,
we would need more or less of that.
The number of peopleis also not stable,
that is in the camp during the year...
So, we're in the process of trying to scale,
but we need to findthe right amount.
We could introduce the wind power, here in the Kamp.
We are actually working together with a company,
that makes recycled plastic, open-source, wind turbines in Belgium.
Trying to figure it outif that would be convenient,
for us to install in the Kamp.
But, this comes with several challenges...
We are surrounded by mimosas for example,
that grow two to three meters a year...
Which, also changes the wind speed that we have now, in Basekamp.
It would come with a noisy, big wind turbine.
If we would install it in another part of the Kamp...
We would need to dig a cable of many meters depending...
But, this would come also with a loss of energy on the way...
Hydro-electric power is something that many people suggested us
in the comments, after seeing the waterfall.
But, whathappens is that the waterfall is not in our land...
So, that part of the of land doesn'tbelong to us...
It wouldn't be convenient to install a new electric station there for us...
It's also around half a kilometer away from our battery storage.
Which, it would come with energy loss on the way...
Where do we put a cable?
Is it in the air?
Do we need to dig it?
A lot of challenges to come here with installations,
and we are still in a temporary setup...
So, our capacity to install these kind of
fixedelectricity suppliers is quite low nowadays...
So, we're scaling up!
Which, it means that systems aregetting pushed...
Which includes, not having enough dried towels...
Maybe the week is overcrowded,
and there is not enough bread, because the bread gets eaten too fast...
We also got some washing basins,
but thewater gets too dirty easily...
Our compost bin -- too tiny.
But, all of them are quite easy to solve!
They're quite practical!
We just take a bigger compost bin...
Buy some new towels...
Install a bread team that bakes more bread...
And, maybe, some new dishwasher buckets.
Easy to solve!
But, there is one biggerproblem, which is a bit shitty...
Let me show you!
So, this brings us to the toilet...
The toilet isgetting quite crowded,
especially during the rush hours...
This means that we would like a new toilet.
But, finding the expert for it, it's quite a challenge...
It's not the biggest challenge...
We have abigger one!
A shittier one even.
Let me show you!
All right!
This brings us to the core of theproblem...
The poo area we are in now...
The poohole of Season 1 got filled up half...
In Season 2, wefilled up one-and-a-half poohole...
And, in the third season, we already filled up the first one,
and wejust started!
This shows how big the problem is!
Come, and let me show you,
what thesystem looks like at the moment...
Currently, we are dropping a bucket ofpoo,
into this hole every time...
Cover it a bit with soil, and some sawdust, to dry it out.
But, the smell increasesduring summer...
We don't really know what to do with it.
The area is also covered by rocks,
which makesit hard for us to dig new holes...
So, what we would like to ask you:
"What to do with all this poo?"
We're opening a research module on the website!
Let's see if we can find a solution!
Almost a thorn in my butt!
So, currently, we livein Basekamp.
And, most of the problems you just saw,
we hope to address them, when we buildthe Community Center.
Because, this building would hold many complex infrastructure.
Energysystems, sewage, water, showers...
It would all be in here!
And, this project is currently in the process of legalization.
We would also need to find funding for that soon-ish..
Which, it's going to be a next big challenge we're going to have...
But, what this building doesn'thave is places to sleep...
This would just be the shared facilities,
for the people to be at during the day.
But, at night, we need houses...
And, this year, in Season 3, for the first time:
we're going to build our Level 2-house.
And, for that, I actually have a special request for you guys,
which should be kind of fun!
Let me show you!
So, the goal is to make a house,
thatis more proper than a tent, but still movable.
So, you don't have all the complexity of the legalpaperwork...
We figured: let's build it on top of a big trailer!
So, me and Adrian went to visit thescrapyard.
And, we started looking into different kinds of trailers,
and boxes that are on top.
And,we found five, different, cool options!
Each has their pros and cons.
Some are good for documentation, and others are more fun.
And, we couldn't decide, so, we figured you guys can decide,
what house we're goingto build up!
So, let me show you the options.
This is the first option!
It's an old pig trailer.
Thisis Adrian here in front.
This container is in very rough condition...
It's been there for a long time...
It requires lots of work, but it's quite unique!
It's a good size, and it's an old trailer!
Very specific, soit's hard to replicate...
But, realistically, I don't think anyone else would ever buy that trailer...
So,it would just rot away, so that would be good,
if we would use it!
And, it's somewhat exciting tostart this one,
because it's bit of an unknown.
Second option: a shipping container!
You know thesethings...
You can get one in a pretty good state!
It's not too much work, because the outer wallsare super good!
It's a good size!
We already have a bunch of them in Basekamp
which is also the downside alittle bit...
Like, it's less fun here...
But, they're useful for documentation,
because everyone can find shipping containersaround the world.
So, having a blueprint ofa house of a container is somewhat useful...
And, it's kind of easy to build, butalso not very challenging...
So, option number three is this fridge box!
Which you can sometimes seeon the back of trailers,
where they put in some ice creams, or when they're cooling things.
You findthese boxes in pretty good state, the one we saw.
It's kind of dirty work to work with this,
because it's all polyester, fiberglass, andpolyurethane foam...
So, with chemical stuff to work with, especially on the land,
you could see it looking ugly on a piece of land.
But, I wouldsay it's very useful to document,
because there are many of these boxes around the world.
I don't thinkany of those get recycled...
So, we could really use some good examples of what to do with that,
instead of that they get burned...
And, I'm also not sure if it's nice to actually live in these things...
With all the fiberglass, and polyurethane around...
So, it feels like it might need some research,
butit's an option as well...
If you guys think that's what we should do.
Option number four is atransport box,
and this one is in pretty good state!
It's quite some work, because currently it lookslike it has walls,
but this is just this canvas material...
So, you need to build an inner, and anouter wall...
But, it would be a very clean base!
It's a good size, and also nice height inside!
And, it seemssomewhat useful as well to replicate!
Because, this is a very common truck trailer around the world.
So, you would easily find it, and it's pretty standardized.
But, it does need a lot of new materials...
Like, you don't have any walls that you can reuse...
We could reuse the tarp, so that's cool!
Allright, option number five: this old blue metal box.
It's in a pretty good state!
It's from the Belgiumtaxes, I think, or the customs?
And, the size is pretty good inside, although it's a bit low
So,it would be nice to extend the roof,
but the roof will probably need to be replaced anyway...
But, thewhole outer walls we can use,
so we only have to build the inner walls.
Which saves a lot of time...
And, it's a bit less specific in documentation.
So, I don't think you necessarily found another box,
like this, around the world...
But, the principle would be to build a house inside of a box.
And, they actuallyhad a similar box here
as well, from the German circus -- a white one...
So, that's also an option, butthey're the same kind of build...
You just have this metal outer wall.
So, this one is pretty neutral, not wild, not boring...
Yeah, it's an option...
So, now on Patreon, you can vote which option we should gofor.
And, we'll pick whatever comes out of the votes.
Kind of scary to do, but, yeah,
I hope it's goingto be okay.
And, if you're not a Patreon you could become one, which is cool!
Because, you would also supportthe project.
Or, leave your comment below.
So, then other Patreons can see it...
And, they can vote to see what
the rest of the world kind of likes in there.
And, the reasons for doing this, is to actually tryout,
to have a bit more of a distributed decision making.
So, it's not just the people in the Kampdeciding, but a bigger audience.
Which, in this case, it's Patreon.
So, if you want to explore, if you canintegrate this,
and do this more in the future...
Anyways, these were all our practical challenges we currently have...
So, now, let's go to a few more human challenges
Which are going to be a little bit more
complex and difficult to explain, so bear with us...
So, about human challenges...
It is abouthow to regulate different types of energy.
This means: for the people that are here short-term,
they come with a boost of energy!
And, they leave all the world and reality that they knowbehind.
They just give everything to Project Kamp!
And, this only happens, because of the people
that come from the outside.
So, a massive thank you!
For us, that stay here for a longer term,
we arejust creating our lives here.
So, we are also holding a big responsibility!
And, we are asking questions on how to separate
work for just a leisure moment.
At the moment, we can't reallydo that very easily,
because we all sleep in Basekamp.
We all eat in Basekamp, we all work inBasekamp,
and we all just are living around in Basekamp.
So, we are trying to figure outways,
that we can balance out this quest.
And, think of strategies that we can integrate,
and stay here more energized longer terms.
So, there is a big challenge...
Which,is finding a balance in between finding a way,
to align everything towards thegoal of the project...
Having people come in that we all care about...
But then, also, having our personalneeds...
And, to balance it out, is very difficult.
This was already difficult within Season 2,
butnow in Season 3, it only becomes bigger...
So, this is nothing new.
We already talked about this during the winter.
But, to bring this in practice, it's still a hard thing to do...
At some point, you just get absorbed by the responsibilities
and you forget about yourself...
But, we found some techniques,
and someways to at least improve it.
Which is: leaving the land every now and then,
or talking with eachother...
Maybe, taking your time for yourself,
and finding out what is that what you need.
Okay, butit's still hard to bring in practice, because we're all
in a small space, and you get carried away by things...
So, sometimes, we're just not able to solve something...
Or, need to say no at a certain point...
Which, is not really nice...
You feel bad, it make you feel stressed,
which comes on top of alreadynot feeling good...
It's not an easy challenge.
We are working on it, but hopefully,
inthe future, this will clear up.
That's it.
So, finally, one last human challenge
is all ofyou guys watching these videos!
Because, we want to make good videos, but it's kind ofhard...
Because, the audience is very diverse!
So, we have people subscribing since Season 1,
when I was just one guy chopping some bushes here...
Or, people subscribing now in Season 3,
where it's way more people, and bigger projects going on!
So, the audience is quite diverse,
and then people also just have different preferences.
Some like fast videos...
Some likea lot of timelapses...
Some like loud music, some soft,
which is a recurring topic in thecomments.
Which makes it kind of hard for us to know what it is...
What does a good video looklike,
and how can we consistently deliver that?
Now, we do have a cool video team here!
These two guys are editing the videos!
But, even that is not super consistent...
Because, they don't know what they're doing next year.
Javier might start a tomato farm,
and Guilherme might start a repair drone shop...
It could easily be the case!
So, it's hard in this setting to be consistent,
in what we want to achieve...
All of this said about video and how challenging it is...
I am aware it's a great advertisement!
We're also still looking for new video makers,
that can jointhis team!
Because, video is an important part of this project.
And, we really want to make sure wedeliver
good videos each week.
So, we could use a hand
If you want to help out, there's a link below to sign up.
And, we could also use some help for people subtitling the videos!
We also havea little team for that now remotely!
So, you can also go to the link below to see.
And then, you canjoin these guys to help out editing the videos!
Anyway, those were our currentchallenges!
Next, we're going to do a Q&A,
where we're going to answer some of you guys' questions.
- What is the most exciting project for
this season?
Most exciting project...
The lagoon obviously!
The yellow van!
Probably, Level 2 house!
The new toilet!
The lagoon!
The whole season is exciting!
Well, of course, it's the yellow van.
This is a house on wheels!
The Level 2 housing...
I think Level2 housing.
I don't know...
- Where do you get all your money from,
and what about food supplies?
The money for building all the cool stuff,
comes from YouTube and Patreon.
Our food suppliescome from four sources mainly.
Which, is a small farm, run by somebody called Nuno.
A bigger farm,run by two people called Nuno, incidentally.
And, two bulk shops, which supply us with different goods.
- Can you show us your video editing setup?
Here it is!
- What's the most useful tool for sanding?
Well, it depends.
If we are doing big jobs, or like rough jobs,
we use the belt sander with 80 gritsandpaper.
And, if we are doing like little surfaces,
or more detail sanding, it's the orbital sander.
With sanding paper of 80, 120, till 180 we go.
So, yeah, that's what we use.
- Regarding dogs, arethere permanent residents or temporary?
- Do they eat vegan food during the week?
For now, Chester and I are staying for the whole season.
At least, he's enjoying himself more than anyone here.
And, he just eats normal dog food during the whole week.
- Vegan, or not vegan?
Not vegan.
- About energy expansion, will youwait until you have
one year of data, or you will do something sooner?
Now, we have a year worth of data
of our solar consumption and solar production.
So, we are already working on it!
But, as I said beforethis is a temporary setup...
So, we need to combine a bit of temporary setup,
with the data we have, with thesolutions we can apply now.
- How does the camp deal with unavoidable garbage?
Despite our best effortto reduce our waste,
there are still some of the waste, that we don't know how to deal with...
So, westill have around like 2 kilos of waste,
going to the 'landfill' every week.
- How do you prioritizeor use advice from the YouTube comments?
We don't have a system to prioritize any YouTube comments,
or advice we get through the platform.
Sometimes, we read things...
Makes sense.
So, we apply them.
Sometimes, we don't really see a way to address them...
- Can I, as a builder, come with my children,
oris it too dangerous for little kids?
The Kamp is not yet very children-proof...
It's at a very raw state, and very 'beginner'.
Hopefully, inthe future, we will have a positive answer to that!
- Has the camp considered getting a resident goat or two?
So, for now, we have enough people.
I think they act like goats sometimes...
- Have you consideredplanting fruit trees,
or wild flowers on your land, with some beehives?
- So, you can produce yourown honey?
I think about it a lot...
Especially, when I see all the orange trees
around here, in the neighborhood...
We're going to plant more this year!
But, if you actually want to see more about it,
we already explained this in Episode 74.
- How do you communicate with each other onyour land?
- Do you use walkie-talkies?
- Are you planning to put glassfiber?
Well, for now, we shout quite a bit...
But, we have a walkie-talkie to communicate,
between the kitchen and theoffice.
We don't intend to lay glassfiber yet...
Maybe a couple of seasons into the future.
- Areyou residents in Portugal?
- Do you need permissions to live in a van on the land?
Yeah, someof us are residents in Portugal!
I don't think you need a permission to live in a van,
if you're having a van on your own private land.
- How's about the highway sounds?
Still there,but I notice them less, for some reason!
Which, is good...
- How do you get all of your ideasfor your projects?
Well, this is the easy part.
Many, many things to do...
Even YouTube comments have somany ideas.
I think, the challenge is more: "How do you filter them?"
Which one do you take on?
- Has Wes Andersonbeing volunteering with the filming?
No, not so far!
- What do you think about caravans?
I don't like thematerials they are made out of...
Usually fiberglass, plastics, not durable...
They change with the time, and they are bit ugly...
And, they don't really fit our setup that good...
- How much did the landcost, when you initially purchased it?
The price was close to 100.000 euros, for 10 hectares ofland.
- How do you organize healthcare for your community members?
I don't think we figured outthis topic...
Most people come temporary,
so they have their own healthcare system.
In their own land, where they're from...
For the long-term members: to be figured out, I would say...
- What do you guysdo for hobbies, or downtime?
Everybody does kind of their own thing, I'd say.
But, there is a gamenight each week...
There is a movie night each week...
So, there's opportunities where we gather
in groups, and have such activities.
- Can you sustain yourself at any kind of income?
So, this questiondoesn't really feel clear...
If I understood well, YouTube revenue is not a lot...
But, it's enoughto keep the project running,
and to make the projects happen, and stuff like that.
And then, for our personal sustaining income wise,
we do have side jobs, or remote jobs.
- Howdo you split work?
- Is there a schedule?
- How much work does one person do,
when it's staying in the Kamp?
Okay, so, we have a schedule -- very lovely!
We meet every Monday morning,
and every Fridayafternoon together.
Inbetween, we just make sure that we feel good
So, we are giving the energywe can give,
and we rest whenever we need to rest.
- Do people with any kind of disability live at Project Kamp?
- And if no, do you have plans to integrate people
with disabilities of any kind?
So far, nobodywith disabilities came to Project Kamp to help.
We are open, but of course,
it depends on thelimitation the disability will bring...
Like, nowadays, we are not wheelchair proof.
But, it depends...
Depends on the disability.
- Have you thought to start recycling,
and creating plastic products forsale from there?
So, so far, we don't sell anything from the Kamp...
We don't have big machinery inthe country and recycled plastic...
And, luckily, we don't have many plastic streams in the Kamp either.
- What is everyone's favorite thing about being at Project Kamp?
The favorite thing about ProjectKamp is the people.
The people.
Yeah, the human beings!
I would say the people!
So many talented people!
Seeing everyone growing personally.
The vision.
All of the lovely dinners that are cooked for us!
And, all of the really friendly people!
Doing everything outside, and living outside.
It gives me the freedom todo what I love,
in the way I like it.
Being part of something bigger, I think.
I like every day!
Life to life, day to day!
Fuck Javier, I don't know man...
Feeling that I do something useful, I think.
I likethat.
You're not gonna get me with this video Javier...
- Do you avoid animal products,
considering their lack of sustainability?
It's one reason, but it'sactually a super complex answer to give...
Last season, we had a video a bit more in depth.
Our decisionmaking around eating,
and maybe you can check that in that video.
- Have you tried the burnt wood methodof conservation?
So, yeah, we tried!
You can check it in update 72!
Last update of Season 2!
And, here it is!
Seems like it's doing well...
Let's see in the longer run.
- How muchdid the tent, and deck project cost?
240 euros for the deck, built here on location.
Sourcing this localsawmill...
And, 600 euro from Eva and Kaegh.
Canvas, materials, prototyping, etcetera.
But, you can stillfind all the information related to this project.
In the research topic, that you can find below.
- Regarding the tent, could it be made with Precious Plastic beams?
Yes, it could be made with recycledplastic beams!
This is a prototype, but a cool idea!
- How's your fireproofing going?
- Have you plannedto dig some more ponds?
Yes, we're working on this!
Clearing a lot of mimosa!
Ponds: still in progress...
- What is the main goal of the project?
This isalways a tough question,
because I think we really don't know...
We sort of have a vague idea.
I thinkthe goal in the short term is to set up a Basekamp.
Invite people, set up infrastructure, so that wecan
properly figure out what our long-term goal is.
But, yeah, it's roughly something about figuring
out how to live sustainable.
And, share all the documentations, and drawings online, for free.
So, thepeople all around the world can replicate it.
But, the details of that are still to be figuredout...
- What happened with the plastic roof built in Update 40?
- And, why didn't you use recycledplastic
to build a roof on top of the container?
The recycled roof is still there, but still in a testing mode.
So, we don't want to make two tests at the same time...
It's going well, but we don'tfeel comfy enough,
to extend these tests to other constructions...
- What is the ratio you try to hit,
between longevity and repairability?
I would say more repairability than longevity,
but longevityvery high too.
Trying to not use new materials,
trying to reuse as much as we can...
And, use muchnatural materials as we can,
to avoid all plastic, glues...
These kind of things are notrepairable, and not natural...
- How many people do work in the project,
and where is the landscape located?
So, at the moment, we are 20,
but we will become 25.
We will also become less, always changing!
And, the project is located in central Portugal.
- Are there any language barriers in the Kamp,
andwhat is the main language?
No, there is a bit of a barrier maybe, with some people,
that don'tspeak Portuguese to speak with the neighbors.
But, yeah, the main language is English.
- What sort of data are you capturing about the project these days?
- And, whatdata do you wish
you were captured that you haven't done yet?
We have some data on
the website
Where we currently gather solar,
internet usage, and water usage.
What Iwould like to get is poop buckets!
To weigh the amount of poop, that comes out of us.
I would really be curious for that!
And, a more practical one is actually the water level in the well.
That it goes up and down that,
and that we can see that it'snot too low in summer...
But, the poop buckets is more fun!
- How do you plan to dig out thepond above the waterfall?
Good question!
We already got the answer!
You will see it soon, in anupcoming update!
- Was there a Kamp Eurovision party?
- How do you keep Adrian from eating all the
bread?
They cannot keep me, Joseph.
- How many people in total will be living in ProjectKamp?
- And, what is the limit?
Throughout the season, the limit capacity,
of what we have right now,is 25.
We never tried it out with so many people,
and we will see how the systems will befunctioning.
In the future, we don't really have a very clear idea
how many people will be living atthe Kamp.
Maybe around 50?
- Support from India: what is the purpose of doing this?
So, I think on theone hand we're trying
just to do something useful...
For what we think is useful for the planet
at the moment, and future generations to come.
But, also making sure, personally for ourselves,
that it's like fun along the way.
And, that it doesn't become a very annoying, boring, heavy thing...
So, Ithink those two things!
Doing something useful, but making sure we enjoy
the road to get thereas well.
that's the purpose of this
And, for the coming plans: in Update 74, you can see all thethings
we're going to do in the coming year.
Hey India!
Okay! That was all for this video!
Hopeyou enjoyed it!
Next video is going to be--
Come on, Guy...
- The next video is gonna be a lagoon update!
So,if you want to watch it now, you can support us on Patreon.
And then, you get towatch the videos one week ahead.
Or, if not, you can subscribe.
And, we'll see youhere next week, same channel.
Ah, and also, if you subscribe to Patreon,
you will beable to vote on the trailer challenge!